I saw of that that was so very
flattering on me no Helen Mirren isn't
dating Keanu Reeves but she's not mad at
the confusion but are you confused
okay let's rewind over the weekend fans
had an all-out freak out when Keanu hit
the red carpet at the LACMA art and film
gala walking hand in hand with artist
alexandra grant the 46 year old rocked
her natural silver hair tied back in a
bun with her bangs down looking a whole
lot like Helen and the Internet you guys
it went freaking wild over it so when et
caught up with Helen and Ian McKellan in
New York City on Wednesday at the
premiere of their new movie the good
liar she addressed the mix-up I saw that
that was very flattering on me you know
because she's obviously lovely yeah so
Helens definitely not dating Keanu
in fact she's been married to director
Taylor Hackford for 22 years how do you
make it work after all these years
what's your secret spending a lot of
time apart although you know it's we do
miss each other terribly when your
apartment I don't know listening to the
other person giving the other person
room to be who they want to be or who
they are you can't change them and
certainly giving them room and support
in their in their profession in their
work but that has to be a two-way street
and I'm very lucky that Taylor gives the
same to me you know it's a mutually
supportive relationship Taylor even
worked with Keanu on the 1997 horror
thriller The Devil's Advocate I'm going
to tell you some things during the
course of this trial that are going to
make you like him even less I do know
Keano very well he did a film with my
husband and he is just the most adorable
lovely person
so she's a lucky girl and I'm sure that
he's a lucky boy
um so lucky Keanu is a freaking Fox but
then again so she but back to Kiana's
actual lady friend
he's known Alexandra for a while now she
Illustrated his 2011 adult picture book
ode to happiness then in 2016 they
collaborated again on another book
shadows and posed together on the red
carpet at a gala in Switzerland they
also started a publishing company
together
that same year I cannot wait to see more
of Keanu and Alexandra their red carpet
moment was the first time Keanu stepped
out with someone in decades and they are
cute with a capital C god I love love of
course you can count on ET to bring you
all the tea on this potential budding
romance so make sure to keep it locked
right here until next time I'm Hallie
Stevens bye for now
[Music]